quand vous êtes en train de devenir une
star ça il faut s'habituer on va vous
poser des questions on va poser des
questions cons parce que on va poser
toutes les questions à un peu imbécile
comme celle là est donc bon boulot le
jingle alibert rouge en mouche ce soir
bien
alors comment j'ai de prêts à les leur
opposer une première question qui est la
question dit clotilde courau c'est une
question qui est inventé par clotilde
courau est ce que par amour vous en bois
seriez sans fois de suite ses
chaussettes sales non non et vous daniel
o moi je réponds pas les questions y
compris des cas ça s'appelle l'interview
venu l'ont même très bien on peut dire
nulles et qu'on a bien sûr alors
maintenant leurs questions la question
cubaine
il est magnifique parce qu'il ya la
question en moins la question
pierre bellemare comment briller vous un
vibromasseur qui se branche sur
l'allume-cigare près d'aleg tel talent
moi j'en ai rien à [ __ ] je fume pas
enfin la raison aux aubrais lentement
vers de monsieur prévost je suis marié
je sais ça fait trois fois bien elles
sont
est-ce que vous préféreriez vous
réincarner écoutez bien en lara fabian
en céline dion ou ans hélène ségara qui
pas lara fabian non je sens que tu as
envie de dire ça je t'aime va bien aller
et la réunion à vis bien c'est l'union à
céline dion c'est bien celle de calais b
punition préférez vous préférez être
privé de sexe ou privés de câlins privé
de 6 millions de j'aime aucune de ces
primes et vous où le raf a bien appris
vite sexe fils une lara fabian
privé de sexe se priver de callac si
vous préférez sexe privé de sexe avec
théo cas là parce qu'avec les câlins je
me dis que ça va car au vu de mon bon ça
peut le faire
c'est vrai donc finalement rangée les
deux quel est le mot le plus con en
amour pour vous merci encore oui oui où
leurs assaillants
oui et non oui oui vous pensez frédéric
diefenthal que pour réussir à la télé il
faut être une ordure un pourri ou un
[ __ ] choix
je crois qu'avec un peu des trois ça
peut marcher bien vous n'avez pas de la
télé va il a répondu c'est pas réussi on
va terminer sur une question de culture
politique l'esprit ni citer les quatre
prétendants de l'opposition pour la
mairie de paris à touches porthos aramis
et l'autre c'est comment des joueurs là
c'est dur c'est dur quels sont les
quatre prétendants balladur oui très
bien je suis soufflé pas souffle pas
marrant tout pleut pas
après trois ans qui viennent dire aucun
virement de toi puis il a dit quelque
chose mais écoute mais quand daniel
prévost ses rivaux lui connaissait pas
non mais c'est pas grave attendait ça
n'a aucune importance je fais simplement
pour montrer que finalement tout le
monde s'en fout ce truc là à dire que la
presse en parle toute la journée toute
la journée la radio par toute la journée
et tout le monde s'en fout la preuve
c'est moins cher mais pas super
important de le savoir si vous allez
répondre olivier en avait trop dit ou
pas assez gains séguin séguin will
tiberi tiberi oui balladur
oui pour l'opposition le gamin il y en a
quatre il ya position séguin
jfm pas une banque en plus étonné que
quand il conduit son taxi dans le film
se disent ah voila je découvre sa
télévision de l'an 2000 c'est le
troisième millénaire air et c'est ça oui